♪
heureux d'être sur scène.
Ce n'est querérérépétition,
mais ils y mettent
toute leur passion.
a rouvert cet été, porté par un
no é é élan, sous la direction
artistique d'Oksana Taranenko.
La pièce vient de s'ajouter
au programme, inspirée d'un
Fini le répertoire russe.
l l les classiques ont été
retirés des spectacles.
Pour Oksana, en fait pour tous
les artistes, c'est le bouclier
le plus puissant contre
la terreur qu'on leur inflige
Et c'est un geste de défiance,
dans cette ville russophone,
fondée au 18e ththththththththt,
dont la statue de bronze
n'est plu u u tout la bienvenue.
Car Vladimir Poutine a toujours
considéré Odessa comme partie
Russie qu'il veut bâtir.
de l'oppression russe,
dit cet historien.
"Elle évoque Vladimir Poutine
dit-il. Elle aisisisisisisisisia
personne, elle reniait les
frontières et voulait redessiner
la carte de l'Europe
comme lui".u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'a
appréhende une attaque majeure,
ou même un débamemement
des troupes du Kremlin.
Les monuments, qui font d'Odessa
le joyau archi'U'U'U'U'U'U'U'U's
d'accès ou protégés.MaMaMaMaMaMe
n'enlèvent rien à la splendeur
de la façade baroque
du grand opéra.
Victor, sa enenenenenenenenener
à Odessa après six mois d'exilde
l'ultime cible de l'invasion
sssssse. Car Odessa n'est pas
qu'un port stratégique et la
porte d'entrée sur la mer Noire,
ce que Vladimir Poutine veut
détruire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Une ville où les cultures se
marient, où chaque coin de rue
témoigne de sa diversité
et de son ouverture.
Une ville à 150 km du front et
où les jeunes ne se laissent pas
abattre par la peur.
Juste avant le couvre-feu,
presque tous les soirs à Odessa,
de l'ennemi.
Les fonds amassés serviront à
acheter des véhicules pour les
soldats qui se b
qu'en ukrainien.
Et lui aussi
♪ ♪ ♪
- Certains jugent la situationpn
accueillant.
- Quand cette touriste française
a dit à sa lllllle qu'elle
partait en vacances à Odessa,
on lui a dit qu'elle était
complè
- On dit comme ça :
"Qui ne risque pas,
il ne boit pas de champagne."
-
pour tant de beauté.
Mais pour ceux qui restent,
l'avenir demeure incertain.
♪ ♪ ♪
Oksana ne se donne
même plus le droit de planifier
les spectacles au-delà
duAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlAlA,
Radio-Canada, Odessa.